Somehow hundreds if not thousands of
people agreed to create a pentagram and
summon the devil. Not just a little
picture of the devil, but there's a
Latin phrase underneath there that says,
"Hear us, Lucifer, and rise from the
abyss. Take our soul." This is not just
family fun, guys. This is a satanic
ritual on a mass scale. Did you know the
origins of spectator sports is literally
a pagan ritual? The ancient Olympics, a
prominent example of spectator sports,
were deeply rooted in religious and
ritualistic practices. It's a total
pagan entertainment package with
religious processions, animal
sacrifices, and a focus on the sacred
sanctuary of Zeus. This is not a
conspiracy theory. You can look this up
on Olympics.com. They'll tell you the
origins of the Olympics, Olympics
mythology. He staged games in Olympia in
honor of Zeus. Zeus was considered the
most important of all Olympic gods. They
openly tell you that spectator sports is
a ritual to false gods. Notice that the
Olympics literally have ceremonies. The
opening ceremony, the closing ceremony.
What is a ceremony? The dictionary
definition of what a ceremony is is a
formal religious ritual. So literally
these are a religious ritual to Zeus.
And who is Zeus? Zeus is a Greek god
that's identical to the Roman god
Jupiter. When you check out Jupiter, he
is the chief Roman god. So all roads
lead to Rome. This is all going back to
sun worship. Some people might say that
this is prejudice against other cultures
and religions. But what does Deuteronomy
32:17 says? They sacrificed unto devils,
not to God, to gods whom they knew not
to new gods that came newly up whom your
fathers feared not. And 1 Corinthians
10:20 goes even further and says, "But I
say that the things which the Gentiles
sacrificed, they sacrificed to devils
and not to God. And I would not that ye
should have fellowship with devils." The
Bible's literally telling us that any
other god, any other idol is literally a
devil, a demon. These people are
worshiping demons. And the ironic part
is they don't even hide it anymore. They
blatantly summon Satan in a pentagram,
and people clap and cheer and act like
it's all fun and games. Which is why
Revelation 12:9 says, "And the great
dragon was cast out, that old serpent
called the devil and Satan, which
deceiveth the whole world." Satan is
here deceiving the whole world, and he
doesn't even have to masquerade as an
angel of light anymore. We are literally
clapping and cheering for a satanic
ritual Satan doesn't even have to hide.
If you guys ever doubted that we're in
the last days, just look around.
Subscribe for more. Candid truth.
[Music]